Hallo, ich hab jetzt ein Ziel gebraucht.
Tschuldigung, ich rufe mich ausgesperrt. Hallo, ich hab jetzt ein Ziel gebraucht. Tschuldigung, ich rufe mich ausgesperrt. Hallo, ich hab jetzt ein Ziel gebraucht. Tschuldigung, ich rufe mich ausgesperrt. Können Sie schon vorbeikommen? Wir sind hier keine Versicherung. Wir haben damit Wir haben damit, also ich rufe Sie einen Schlüssel. Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Sind wir jetzt schon? Wir sind wir. Wir sind nicht mehr das Intro. Das ist das Podcast, das Projekt Est 2017. Die Stimme, die du gerade gehört hast, war nicht live. Okay, woher kommt die? Von Tobias. Tobias, okay. Tobias hat das Intro gemacht. Aber Tobias hat nicht ... Und war das noch ein Ausschnitt aus dem Podcast-UFO-Projekt? Ja, genau. Oder sind wir jetzt schon ... Aber das war PDT. Remixen wir jetzt schon ... Ist es ein Meme? Nein, nein, nein. Ist das Intro ein Meme geworden? Das weiß ich nicht. Ich kenne mich nicht gut aus mit Memes. Okay. Also ich meine, in gewissen Chronosphären bin ich ein Meme. Hier dieser Ring, also dieser Chefs Kiss, der Perfekt, wenn man auf Tinder zum Beispiel Perfekt sucht bei den Gifs, dann komme ich. Davon kennt man mich vielleicht, also falls ihr jetzt nicht wisst, mit wem ihr es zu tun habt, ich bin der Typ von dem Chefs Kiss Meme. Und ich bin der, der im Wald, wo die Kamera drauf zuzoomt und der dann freundlich lächelnd grinst und nickt. Ja, mit dem karierten Hemd. Der mit dem karierten Hemd, das bin ich mit dem Bart. Mittlerweile siehst du anders aus, fünf Jahre später, aber... Wieso? Naja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass sich die Leute jetzt wirklich erkennen und oft ansprechen. Du bist doch der Typ, der so nickt, der so zustimmt nickt. Oder? Ich glaube, das liegt eher das Gif nicht so, es ist zwar bekannt, aber es ist nicht weltbekannt. Sehr bekannt, schon sehr bekannt. Aber ich meine, du hast also diesen Holzfäller, die Holzfällerphase, da bist du aber wirklich blitzartig wieder raus. Du hast nicht mal einen Baum gefällt, du hast drei-, viermal reingehackt. Ich habe nur das Meme, ich habe nur dieses Gif. Okay. Und ich finde es so doof, dass ich jetzt nicht mehr erkannt werde. Klar, vielleicht sollte ich wieder anfangen, einfach Holzfällerhemden zu tragen. Macht man Stefan zuliebe einfach, sprecht ihn mal an auf der Strasse und sagt, sag mal, bist du nicht der von dieser Holzfäller-Meme? Und weil ich mich immer an nichts erinnern kann, was ich jemals gesagt habe im Podcast, wo sage ich dann, was? Und gehe dann verärgert, basically weg. Bist du nicht der Holzmemer, Holzfiever? Ach? Nein. Ich habe heute tatsächlich, ich habe gerade heute auf dem Weg hierher versucht, lustig zu sein, weil, wir nehmen an Köln auf, ja, ich bin auf dem Weg, und dann werde ich angesprochen von einer alten, verwirrten Frau, ja, also sind wir ehrlich. Direkt die Klage, direkt einfach der Anwalt, direkt ins Haus. Was haben Sie gesagt? Mein Gag wäre eher Wutmail, man sagt nicht mehr Alte, verwirrte Frau. Ach so, okay. Sondern man sagt eher Orientierungslos oder Alters Weird oder was anderes Unverfängliches. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Hate Mails. Kam auf mich zu, ich natürlich tief eingewickelt, Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer, darüber zwei Mützen gezogen. Mein ganzer Körper schreit, ich will nichts mit dir zu tun haben, aber natürlich eine Haltung. Mein ganzer Körper sagt doch, du willst nicht raus. Ich will nicht raus. Du bist nicht viel draußen gemacht. Ich habe meinen Schildkrötenpanzer ganz fest um mich herum. Da ist kein Spiel mehr. Die Augen, kleine Schlitze, zu kleinen Schlitzen zusammengefahren, Mund weit offen. Die Welt ist fast ausserhalb von mir, kommt kaum rein. Und die meinte dann so, ja, kennen Sie sich hier aus. Und an dem Punkt denke ich mir schon, ich werde nie der Mensch sein, der diese Frage bejaht. Nie. Egal wo, egal was, ich glaube, man könnte mich in meinem Heimatort ansprechen und sagen, kennen Sie sich hier aus? Ich würde sagen, nee, nicht so, aber, aber ich versuch's mal. Nee, du willst gross strugglen, erst mal deine Kopfhörer, erst mal, du würdest nicht verstehen, dass du gemeint bist. Dann hast du deine Kopfhörer auf, dann viel Fumbling, Fumbling, Fumbling, dann fällt dir ein Kopfhörer runter oder sowas, die Kapuze fällt runter, oh nein, und dann steuert dir diese, was von deinen Hoodies, diese Dinger, diese Baumeldinger, eins in dein Auge, oh nein, ups, sorry. Dann habe ich unter den Kopfhörern noch so in ihr, die haben noch so ein Kabel und wenn ich die rausziehe, wird das Handy auch rausgezogen, das fällt nochmal zu Boden. Handy fällt zu Boden und zerbricht. Du willst aber trotzdem nett sein, irgendwie darauf antworten, sie fragt, kennst du dich hier in deinem Heimatort aus? Schneeflocke ins Auge. Schneeflocke fliegt ins Auge und du sagst, nee, passt schon, ich frage einfach jemand anderen.
Ich habe gar nicht mit dir gesprochen.
Aber wirklich, ich glaube, ich könnte diese Frage nie mit Ja beantworten.
Niemals, egal wo.
Ich glaube, man könnte in meiner eigenen Wohnung mich fragen, kannst du mir kurz eine Frage beantworten?
Ich sage, vielleicht grob, vielleicht grob in die Himmelsrichtung.
Wo liegen die Messer?
Ich habe ein Messer mal da vorne gesehen.
Nein, das ist das Katana aus
Kill Bill, was du ersteigert hast.
Messer ist nämlich nur einseitig.
I wanna die. Und ja,
lass uns doch zusammen Messer suchen. Ich bin nämlich
auch, ich bräuchte sie auch.
Und dann fragt mich diese
alte Frau so, ja,
sie sagt so, ja, okay, dann probier's mal,
vielleicht kann ich ja helfen. Und sie fragt, ja, ich such den Dom. Und ich denke mir, jetzt ist meine Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, ja, okay, dann probier's mal, vielleicht kann ich ja helfen. Und sie fragt, ja, ich such den Dom. Und ich denke mir, jetzt ist meine Chance und antworte mit, Dom habe ich nie gehört. Ich mir dachte so, das muss jetzt schon sein. Wir kriegen nicht umsonst... Danke an unseren Hörer Florentin, der die sehr lustige Situation eingereicht hat. Könnt ihr auch, per Sprachnachricht, einfach immer eine lustige Geschichte, die ihr erlebt habt. 0800 Pufo-P-P. Pufo-Nase. Es war zu kurz, wir mussten es noch verlängern. Und das war frei. Ich dachte mir, den musste ich einfach mitnehmen, musste ich einfach mitnehmen, hab dann aber direkt, also nach dem schallenden Schweigen von ihr, nachdem sie sich vor Schweigen den Bauch gehalten hat, habe ich dann gesagt, nein, nein, kein Problem und man konnte den Dom sogar sehen. Okay. Also es war wirklich so diese Paris-Situation, wo ich gesagt habe, der Dom ist genau da.
Man kann ihn wirklich sehen, habe aber nicht bedacht, dass sie vielleicht nicht so gut
sehen kann, weil sie hat fragend in die Leere gestarrt und gesagt, ich sehe nichts. Er hat sie gesehen, ich sehe nichts, das war nicht der Wortlaut. Ich habe gesagt, da, also es war ein bisschen verregend. Ach so, ich sehe den Dom nicht. Nein, sie sagte, guck mal, sie können den Dom sogar von hier sehen, ich sehe nichts, und ich habe gesagt, ja, vorne und rechts. Also das hat so ... Genervt in dem Ton? Ja, schau dir, es hat schon. Genervt von ihren altersschwachen Sehfähigkeiten? Ja, da vorne und rechts. Ja, da vorne und rechts, Mensch, das sieht man doch. Mein Gott, das ist doch offensichtlich. Aber ich war, er ist jetzt sehr froh, dass ich den Sehbruch. Ich vorstelle, dass jemand so durch die Welt geht und so schnell genervt ist von den fehlenden Fähigkeiten, von den fehlenden Sinnen von anderen Menschen. Da vorne rechts. Mein Gott, da vorne rechts. Wo rechts? Da vorne rechts, mein Gott! Einfach viel zu viel Energie auch. Genau, so viel Energie hätte ich noch nie in meinem ganzen Leben, würde ich überhaupt. Aber cool. Aber sie wird jetzt durch die Welt gehen und die Geschichte anders erzählen, dass sie diesen jungen, verrückten Menschen getroffen hat, der sich erstmal aus seinem Schneckenhaus raus gebildet musste. Und der hat dann gesagt, da ist der Dom, da schau ich da hin und da ist nix. Erstmal hat er gesagt, ja gut, da versuche ich mich gar nicht an diesem Dialekt erst. Nimm anderen. Ähm, nee, ich wollte es auf Hochdeutsch versuchen. Erstmal hat er gesagt,
dass der Dom gar nicht in Köln
stünde, wo doch allen klar ist,
ja, der Dom steht in Köln.
Da fliegt doch der Dom
aus Köln raus, sagt man ja.
Home is where the dome is.
Ja, aber hat nicht geklappt.
Scheiße, aber ich glaube, Gags
generell funktionieren nicht.
Nein, Gags funktionieren nicht,
es klappt nicht. Aber wo wir gerade
Es ist ein, das wir jetzt nicht Gags generell funktionieren nicht. Nein, Gags funktionieren nicht, es klappt nicht. Aber wo wir gerade gesprochen haben über Hörernachrichten, ich muss noch eine abhaken, weil tatsächlich es ist immer so ein bisschen die klassische Dramaturgie der Hörernachricht. Ja, wir sagen, hey Leute, schickt uns und dann schicken die und wir freuen uns und dann hören die aber nicht auf, das zu schicken, so Woche für Woche für Woche für Woche und es ist immer noch interessant. You're preaching to the choir. Es ist immer noch interessant, aber irgendwann denkt man sich, das haben wir doch jetzt schon abgehakt. Das stimmt. Und es gibt aber eine Ausnahme, von einer Sache kriege ich nicht genug. Selbst wenn mir schon davon schlecht ist, würde ich mir das immer noch reingehen. Selbst wenn mein Arzt mir sagen würde, nicht mehr nach 18 Uhr, würde ich trotzdem die Mail noch aufmachen. Selbst wenn ich wüsste, dass ich dann die Nacht nicht schlafen kann, würde ich trotzdem die Mail lesen. Was für eine Mail? Welche Mails? Ich krieg den Bauch nicht voll. Wenn deine Ast scheisse kommt, welche Äste sehen aus wie Musikinstrumente scheisse kommen, dann verlasse ich den Raum. Ich hatte heute schon drei, aber ich nehme gerne noch einen und genieße ihn wie den ersten.
Und zwar unsere lieben Hörernachrichten zum Thema Berufsberatung. Da geht mir immer das Herz auf. Wir hatten vor einigen Wochen nämlich das Thema Berufsberatung, wir haben auch von unseren tollen Vorschlägen gesprochen, die wir damals bekommen hatten. Ich sollte ja irgendeine Form von Betriebswirt werden.
Ich glaube, jegliche Abstinenz von künstlerischen Berufen in meiner Top-20-Liste zeugt davon, dass ich entweder a den falschen Job habe, b mich umorientieren sollte oder der Berufsberater den falschen Job hat oder c der, der Berufsberater. Das kann natürlich auch was sein. Aber es
kamen schon sehr gute Vorschläge, wir haben auch sehr viele
sehr konträre, sehr spezielle.
Estrich Verleger meets Modelberater.
Marionettenspieler, wir hatten schon spannende
Sachen dabei, aber deswegen verstehe ich das sehr gut.
Total, und diese Woche
kam rein, hat mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen, die Erzählung
von einer Freundin. Eine Freundin, er hat den Job,
war alles in Ordnung, aber die hatte
keinen Bock mehr auf den Job. Aber das heißt, wir sind schon in der die Mail ist schon in der zweiten Ordnung. Genau, erzählt von erzählt. Macht's jetzt schon schlechter. I'm sorry, man kann sehr gute Geschichten erzählen. Du drehst auch schon mal den Multiplikator auf 0,7 runter. Ja, genau, ich dreh das Volume ein bisschen runter. Machen dich ein bisschen leiser. Aber ich fand die Geschichte schön, weil sie ist eine andere Erzählung. Jeder kennt die Berufsberatungsanekdote, aber jede Berufsberatungsanekdote hat doch nochmal einen eigenen Geschmack und eine eigene Geschichte und einen eigenen Menschen, der dahinter steht. Aber anders als bei anderen hatten wir jetzt auch, wir hatten schon sehr viele Ordnungen, also siebter Ordnung oder so, eine Erzählung, wo es dann schon so Myth wurde. Meine Mutter hat einen Song gehört von jemandem, der mit dem in der Schule war, der gesagt hat, dass jemand vor 20 Jahren so. Da waren wir auch schon und haben trotzdem schreien. Und dann war es wahrscheinlich nicht ein Magnettenspieler, sondern Betriebswirt. Und man denkt sich, irgendwann wurde was, diese Geschichte musst du spannender erzählen, Mama. Und dann wurde da irgendwas Größeres draus. Aber deswegen freut es mich ja dann doch, deswegen möchte ich den Multiplater wieder hochdrehen, dass wir bei erster Ordnung sind, weil das ist ja echt entspannt. Das ist gut. Und zwar, ein Hörer hat mir geschickt, eine Freundin von ihm, er hatte einen Job und hat sich da nicht mehr wohlgefühlt, weil sie wollte Polizistin werden. Traumjob, Polizistin, sagt jetzt vielleicht, ich will Leuten helfen, ich will raus in die Welt, ich will Gutes tun, ich will für Gerechtigkeit sorgen, ich will mein Leben verändern. Und ab und zu mal einfach einen Taser in den Augapfel reinstecken. Und ich will einen Hund. So. Und einfach zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe. Und dann musste sie aber in dieser Übergangsphase sich irgendwie beim Jobcenter oder Arbeitsamt, musste sie diesen Berufsorientierungstest machen. Das finde ich so seltsam, dass man das Leuten verschreibt, die sehr genau wissen, was sie wollen.
Das heißt aber jetzt haben wir hier diese Person,
wir nennen sie mal Petra.
Petra will jetzt Polizistin werden.
Sie geht also in diesen Test hinein,
mit quasi schon der Antwort im Kopf.
Das heißt, sie geht jetzt da rein und natürlich die Frage, ja, ähm.
Okay, Petra, setzen Sie sich erst mal. Dankeschön. Wir haben ein paar Fragen für Sie, es wird ganz einfach für Sie. Ja, kein Problem. Alles klar, okay, einfach ganz entspannen. Mhm, okay. Ups, Entschuldigung. Ups, bin ich mir... Hast du wehgetan? Ja, ein bisschen. Ich bin mit der Kniescheibe ein bisschen doof gegen den Tisch. Oh, das tut mir leid, ich kann eine Erste Hilfe auch. Ah, okay, können Sie Erste Hilfe? Ich kann eine Erste Hilfe. Das ist sehr spannend, um zu wissen. Ich habe auch einen Führerschein. Ah, okay, alles klar. Das schreibe ich mir direkt schon mal auf.
So, aber die erste Frage für unseren Berufsinformations...
Also erstmal bitte die Elektroden bitte anlegen an Ihren Kopf.
Ah ja, klar. Natürlich, gerne.
Damit wir wissen, dass Sie nicht lügen. Und falls Sie lügen, dass wir das...
Nee, noch nicht... Achso, jetzt. Ja, genau.
So, alles klar. Einfach dann nochmal durchatmen.
Ich stelle erst ein paar normale Fragen.
Wie ist Ihr Vorname?
Äh, Petra.
Wie ist Ihr Nachname? Äh, Webels Müller. Was ist Ihr... Okay. Können Sie nochmal Ihren Nachnamen sagen? Webels Müller. Alles klar. Ihr Sternzeichen? Krebs. Okay, super. Alles klar. Das waren die Testfragen. Jetzt muss ich das Gerät kalibrieren, damit Sie keine Lügen erzählen. Okay, erste Frage. Wollen Sie gerne mit Menschen arbeiten? Ja. Das kam doch schnell. Sehr klar. Zweite Frage. Wollen Sie lieber alleine arbeiten? Nein. Frage drei. Würden Sie gerne Menschen verhaften? Ja. Frage vier. Sind Sie ein Hund oder ein Katzenmensch? Hund. Oder anders? Hund. Wie würden Sie reagieren, wenn Sie jemand als Bullenschwein bezeichnet? Ordnungsstrafe.
150 Euro. Die nächste Frage. Sehen Sie sich in den nächsten fünf Jahren an Strippen kleine Puppen bewegen?
Nein.
Schweisse auf der Stirn.
Okay, ich nehme das mal zur Kenntnis. Direkt die Anschlussfrage daran. Warum nicht?
Warum denn nicht?
Ich möchte eher mit Menschen arbeiten und was Gutes tun für die Gesellschaft. Mit Marinetten tut man doch was Gutes. Also diese altmundische Forschung ist immer alleine. Es gibt verschiedene Gruppen von Marinettenspielern. Aber wir machen jetzt mal weiter. Wollen Sie Kinder eher A glücklich oder eher B traurig machen?
Glücklich, würde ich sagen.
Ah, okay. Ja, cool, super cool.
Sprechen Sie gerne vor grossen Menschenmengen?
Habe ich kein Problem mit.
Würden Sie lieber, würde es Ihnen einfacher fallen, über Handpuppen eine grosse Menschenmenge zu erreichen? Ich habe das Gefühl, Sie nehmen den Text nicht so richtig ernst. Ich glaube, eher schwerer. Es würde mir eher schwerer fallen über Handpuppen, ne? Also es würde Ihnen a, eher schwerer, eher schwerer, schwieriger fallen, mit Handpuppen für grosse Menschenmengen zu sprechen. Genau, Gut, damit fällt Polizist schon mal raus, weil man da ja bei der Verkehrsberatung immer mit Handpuppen... Ah, fuck! Nein! Aber nur so, also... Und sie hat diesen kompletten Test gemacht mit Polizistin vor Augen, was natürlich erstmal moralisch natürlich fragwürdig ist. Weil natürlich musst du
nein, nein, nein, nein, Petra,
du musst reinen Herzens, du musst reinen Herzens
nicht zu ihm, du musst reinen Herzens
in den Test gehen, das geht nicht.
Ich muss euch vorstellen, ich bin recht, es ist eine große, so eine Lava,
so eine kleine, gut überwindbare
Lavaspur, und man kann sich immer
entscheiden. Gut überwindbar? Naja, man kann einfach drüber
hopsen. So ein Lava-Rinnsaal, einfach so
ein kleines... Ja genau, es ist aber wichtig für die Metapher, weil ihr müsst euch immer zu einem stellen, was die Meinung angeht. Aber komm Petra, komm zu mir, weil ich bin der Meinung, du hast alles richtig gemacht, moralisch ist es auch nicht verwerflich. Wenn du genau weißt, was du willst und du bist trotzdem zu diesem dusseligen Kacktest gezwungen, hast du allen Recht, dich da durchzumogen. Nein, aber das ist doch wie bei Harry Potter mit dem Zauberstab. Wenn du unbedingt einen willst, kriegst du den gerade nicht. Du musst gerade eben von deinen Bedürfnissen loslassen.
Nee, ich finde es wie bei Harry Potter mit dem Zauberhut. Wenn du genau sagst, du willst nicht zu Slytherin, dann kommst du nicht zu Slytherin. So, jetzt habe ich dich mit dem gleichen Franchise besiegt. Okay, ich geh mal einen Schritt zurück.
Einen Punkt für dich auf jeden Fall.
50 Punkte für Gryffindor.
Okay, das ist ein guter Punkt.
Auf jeden Fall hat sie diesen kompletten Test gemacht, hat Polizistin vor Augen gehabt, hat sich auch ganz gut gefühlt danach, dachte, ja klar, in die Richtung soll es gehen. Und dann kam das Ergebnis. Und es ist wieder, das mag ich schon, es ist wieder eine Kombination aus zwei Berufs. Ah, okay. Es sind wieder zwei Berufs. Das zieht sich durch. Also es scheint einfach so ein Entweder-Oder. Man muss schon noch eine Wahl haben. Also Petra geht rein, macht diesen kompletten Test von A bis Z, Ziel ist Polizistin. Ergebnis ist Goldschmied oder Gerber. Oh mein Gott, was wie eine alte Podcast-Upo-Folge klingt, ehrlich gesagt. Goldschmied oder Gerber? Oh mein Gott, was wie eine alte Podcast-Upo-Folge klingt, ehrlich gesagt. Goldschmied oder Gerber? Und ich liebe alles daran, einfach, dass es auch so mittelalterliche Berufe sind. Gerber? Wieso, mir ein Lederhaut von einem Tier abziehen? Oder halt Goldschmied. Es klingt wie, als hätte als wäre die Abgabe morgen für die Berufe und der, der es macht, spielt gerade Stronghold zwei und wusste jetzt nicht. Ja, Beruf, äh, König, schreib halt drei auf, die dir einfallen. Ambrust, Ambrustbauer, Gerber und Goldschmied. Ja, super, komm, mach rein. Ja, ich find's so fantastisch, aber ich find's auch so geil, sich in die, in Petra hineinzuversetzen, die sich denkt, okay, ich hab das genäht, Polizistin. Wie dumm bin ich eigentlich, Goldschmied, Gerber, komplett daneben. Aber wie fragt man denn nach Goldschmied?
Also das muss ja, also was für Fragen kommen denn darin vor, dass Goldschmied eine sehr, vor allem wie, selbstbewusst sind diese Leute, die die Ergebnisse mitteilen.
Das ist so spezifisch. Das ist fantastisch.
Ich habe noch niemals einen Rat gegeben, der so spezifisch war.
In meinem ganzen Leben.
Überhaupt nicht.
Selbst bei Leuten, die ich viel besser kenne als die Leute, diese fremden Menschen, die da hinkommen und sagen, was sie beruflich machen wollen. Ja. Und ich verstehe nicht, ist jemals die Frage gefallen, ja was wollen sie denn machen? Nee. Und sie sagt, weil das ist doch auch für Suchende. Ich verstehe immer nicht, warum muss man denn, man kann auch Leuten, die was machen wollen. Ja, aber vielleicht bist du nicht in dem am besten, was du machen willst.
Die Diskussion hatten wir auch schon ein paar Mal. Vielleicht willst du Polizistin werden, aber vielleicht ist sie die beste Gerberin der Welt. Und uns würde so viel gutes Leder durch die Lappen gehen, wenn wir sie nicht am Gerbstuhl haben. Und dann wäre es so lustig, wenn man dann so einen Zeitsprung macht. Und dann man so in so einer hintersten Ecke, so der Mond steht stark steil am Himmel und macht so ein spitzes Licht und so wirft so lange Schatten auf dem Asphalt und so eine kleine Gasse, so eine Seitengasse, da ist dann dieser Berufsinformationstyp, steht dann da und kriegt von so einer Gestalt, in so einer Kapuzengestalt mit einem Trenchcoat einen Umschlag, sehr viel Geld. Bitz blitzelt kurz durch, der Mond scheint auf dieses Geld. Und dann sehen wir den Typen mit der, ist der Gerber, den wir kennengelernt haben, in Akt 1 haben wir ihn kennengelernt. Ach so, okay, ich dachte, so geht der Film los. Okay, wie sieht der aus, der Gerber? Okay, dann geht der Film so los, dann geht er in seinen ... Du kannst doch deine Vision umsetzen, du musst dich nicht bei ersten Widerstand sagen.
Okay, dann machen wir das ganz anders.
Sorry, ich bin so gebrannt, Marc, von der Branche, wo man noch bei jedem Widerstand einkriegt muss.
Oh, wow, erzähl uns später mehr.
Erzähl uns morgen.
Wo er dann rausgeht und dann geht er in den Laden rein, auf dem steht ganz gross Gerber.
Ja, Gerberei.
Ich bin Gerber.
Und das ganze Publikum. Aber Goldschmied. Aber ich mag euch nicht vorstellen, weil es gibt ja viele so Cremie-Franchises von so Renegade-Cops. Ich brauche keine Marke, um für die Gerechtigkeit zu kämpfen. Oder so, der wird vom Jackson, ihnen wird der Fall entzogen. Sie sind zu hart mit der Zeugin umgegangen. Und er, ich weiß, dass sie schuldig ist, ich werde sie zur Gerechtigkeit bringen, hier ist meine Waffe, so und dann macht er alleine weiter. Und genau so diese Figuren, die eigentlich nicht zum Polizeiapparat gehören, aber trotzdem Polizeiarbeit leisten, so diese Sherlock Holmes, diese Doktor House, keine Ahnung, die so andere Sachenallbrecher, keine Ahnung, aber halt so, die so andere Sachen machen. Aber ja, er ist schon noch kaum. Aber er ist schon noch ein Arzt. Aber halt so Leute, die... Hör auf mit Referenzen um die zu werfen. Nimm Doktor Hauss Namen nicht in den Mund. Okay, wow. Sorry. Nee, guck's gerne einfach mal. Nee, ich mach's. Aber ich mag einfach die Geschichte von dieser Story, von dieser Polizistin, die eigentlich Gerberin ist, aber nebenbei Kriminalfälle löst. Oder Goldschmiedin und plötzlich kommt jemand und sagt, das ist ein Überfall. Genau, und sie erinnert sich. Und plötzlich erinnert sich an ihren altersvergessenden Traum und drückt nicht auf den roten Knopf, den wir in Akt 1 gesehen haben. Sondern sie dreht ihm den Arm um und legt ihn Handschellen an aus Gold. Und das ist unser Cover. Ah, nice. Die Goldschmiedpolizistin. Kommissarin Gold. Das ist auch ihr Nachname, Petra Gold. Und sie löst alles mit Gold. Nice, finde ich super geil. Finde ich richtig gut. Und jeder Fall hat... Da lächelt sie und dann sieht man ihr den Goldzahn aufblitzeln. In jeder Fall hat irgendwas mit Leder zu tun.
Also sie kann auch dann ihre zweite Leid ...
Vielleicht für Staffel zwei?
Leg es auf in Staffel zwei Staffel.
Multi-Season-Perspective.
Leg es auf, alle schlechten Ideen kommen in Staffel zwei.
Fluridins Ideen ist der Staffel zwei Ordner.
Ja, aber sehr gut. Finde ich super gut.
Finde ich richtig gut.
Ich hoffe, Petra geht es gut. Sie heißt nicht, Petra, aber ich hoffe, sie konnte Polizistin werden, wenn sie da Bock drauf hat. Aber in was für einer Welt, weil doch, ich glaube nämlich schon, um nochmal kurz diese leidige, leidige, leidige Diskussion aufzumachen. Man ist darin am besten, was man am liebsten mag. Macht das, viele fragen mich, Stefan, was soll ich eigentlich mit meinem Leben anfangen, ich weiß nicht, was ich will. Und ich sage immer allen das, was ich mal irgendwo anders in dem Podcast gehört habe, macht das, was ihr machen würdet, wenn ihr progressiniert.
Ja, werdet Masturbator.
Masturbator.
Samenspender.
Zum Beispiel.
Ja, okay.
Ich finde es auch erst mal originell. Da kann man sich jetzt erst mal an etwas reiben. Es ist nicht mehr so abstrakt, dieser luftleere Raum. Da kann man jetzt erst mal sich gemeinsam dran reiben. Das ist deine Berufsberatung. Zieh erst mal dein Schert aus. Ich meine, du kannst so viel Geld sparen durch Titel Berufsberatung. Mach das, was du machst, wenn du nichts machst. Mach das, was du machst, wenn du nichts machst. Die Berufsberatung macht Spaß. Mit Stefan. Ja, aber es gibt ja auch legendäre Geschichten von Leuten, die wahnsinnig gut waren in Sachen, das sie gar nicht mochten. Bob Ross hat das Malen gehasst. Hat das Malen gehasst. Hitler hingegen wollte lieber malen. Ja, das stimmt. Hätte man die, naja. Ja, ja. Moment, du meinst, Hitler war richtig gut, aber wollte es gar nicht mehr.
Nee, nee. Jetzt haben wir uns selber ein bisschen zu verraten. Okay.
Bob Ross ist schon ein gutes Beispiel dahingehend, er wollte nämlich nicht malen, ist aber sehr gut und bringt sehr viele Menschen ins Glück.
Meinst du, wenn Hitler den Krieg gewonnen hätte?
Prinz Friedrich von Homburg. Ja. Wollte er das nicht erscheinen lassen? Wollte er verbrennen, ja. Wollte er verbrennen. Ja. Ja, schau mal. Manchmal geht es darum. Was würden wir heute ohne den Prinz von Homburg machen? Ja, was würden wir ohne den machen? Quasi unnötig. Also ich, mich würde es so nicht geben. Nee. Anders, klar. Du wärst anders. Ich wär anders. Ich glaub, du hättest ein Ohrring. Ich glaub, du hättest so ein Detail anders. In der Paralleldimension, wo es den Prinz Friedrich von Homburg und Heinrich von Kleist nicht gibt, hab ich einen Ohrring. Wenn wir jetzt mal in die Dimension schauen, wo es den Prinz von Homburg nicht gibt. Ich glaub, du säst genauso hier, hättest genau den Podcast, aber hättest einen Ohrring. Und alle würden sich fragen, ist das das Einzige? Also was ist die Lawine, die letztens da endet? Also was ist der Butterfly-Effekt, der beim Ohrring endet? Was hat der noch auf dem Weg mitgerissen? Und endet heißt in dem Fall, ob ich ihn trüge oder nicht, würde danach keine anderen Entscheidungen mehr. Ja, genau. Also der Baum würde da enden. Das ist ein Kausalitätsende, genau. Wieso? Wenn ich einenring trage oder nicht, ändert das, macht keinen Unterschied. Nee, ab dann nicht mehr, bis dahin schon, aber ab dann nicht mehr. Ja, aber was du damit sagst, ist, dass es niemanden jucken würde auf der ganzen Welt, ob ich einen Ohrring tragen würde. Nicht in der Dimension, wo du den schon lange hattest. Das erste Jahr würden sich die Leute schon daran reiben, ja, das schon. Aber an einem gewissen Punkt, glaube ich, hätte das irgendwie so den Reiz verloren. Ja, nee, ich glaube, ja. Und wie würde ich aussehen in einer Dimension, wo das das beliebteste Franchise wäre? Wo der Prinz Friedrich von Homburg so ein Star-Wars-artiges Franchisegrösse hat. Ich glaube, du wärst großer Kleist-Fan, hättest ein Kleist-T-Shirt an und und du hättest so seinen Augenbrauen-Cut. Den hat ja Kleist erfunden tatsächlich, Augenbrauen-Cut. Der hat das erste Mal so einen Augenbrauen-Cut, so ein Stück wegrasiert. Okay, das würde dir auch nicht, das wäre so gut, wenn das hätte. Was dir stehen würde, wäre wirklich ein Augenbrauen-Piercing. Habe ich auch mal schon mal drüber nachgedacht, kurz. Nein, das will ich. Ne, habe ich auch nicht. Niemals. Ich hätte auch viel zu viel Angst, dass ich daran irgendwie hängen bleibe oder so. Das ist wenn man, weil ich bin ja wirklich schnell unterwegs, auch viel in Geäst. Ich bin viel in Geäst unterwegs. Und ich habe einmal, wie wir es im Intro gerade noch mal sehr plastisch vor Augen und vor Ohren geführt bekommen haben, habe ich mir ein Ziel gebrochen. Und deswegen, ich brauche eher weniger Extremitäten. Ich glaube, wenn ich mich für irgendeine Körperanpassung entscheiden würde, wäre es eher noch stromlinienförmiger zu werden, weniger mehr Extremitäten zu bekommen. Also ich würde eher versuchen, jetzt mal, lose Ideen, die Arme zusammenführen. Also dass man so eine Art, also dass man wie so ein Pflug immer ist. Also dass du halt schneller bist quasi. Aber jetzt wird es wieder ringenförmig. Jetzt würde ich sagen, dann mach doch lieber die Arme kürzer, weil du willst, glaube ich, du willst weniger Ringe, du willst weniger, an denen du dich festhängen kannst. Korrekt, korrekt, ja. Ja genau, wenn du die Arme zusammenführst, hast du ja zwangsläufig irgendwo eine Öffnung, an der man nicht so festmachen kann. Wie so ein Fahrradschloss kann man nicht dann irgendwo parken. Das ist meine grösste Angst. Kinder kann man nicht wie ein Hund draußen festmachen. Ja, das stimmt. Man kann aber schon viel festmachen. Stimmt auch nicht, man kann die festmachen. Mit einem zum Beispiel. Nur als Beispiel, nicht dass man sollte, aber man könnte sie mit einem Fahrradschloss, was enger ist als der Kopf von der ... Aber was ist mit der Nase? Weil die beiden Nasenlöcher werden doch irgendwann zu eins, oder? Hat man dann nicht so eine Art Loch oder so? Das ist zu tief. Aber genau dazu passend muss ich sagen, ich habe mir einen Traum erfüllt diese Woche.
Ich mir auch.
Okay.
Okay, du zuerst.
Danke.
Dann lege ich los.
Und los geht's hier mit der Stadt Nummer eins.
Und zwar der großen Traumschau der Anekdoten Olympiade 2023.
Martin Will.
Nun, Martin Will. Okay. Und wir hier im Magnesiumpulver an der Hand. Wir wünschen viel Erfolg. Der Trainer Ebersberg mit der Startnummer eins. Florentin Will, wir bitten um Ruhe. Ich habe mir diese Woche einen Traum erfüllt. Und zwar war mein Traum lange die ...
Oh, wer ...
Entschuldigung.
Die Riecht die Linienrichter. Die Jury ist irritiert. Die Jury schaut sich an.
Die schaut sich an. Hallo, mein Name ist Mareike Amado aus der Jury. Okay.
Wir haben beschlossen, dass sie noch eine zweite Chance bekommt.
Dankeschön, vielen Dank.
Ich schaue ins Publikum.
Meine Mutter sitzt dort.
Neben Meister Yoda, der dir einfach nur so zunickt.
Und mir, und ich, wie das Meme.
Du mit dem Yoda-T-Shirt, ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ja, genau, du drehst sie zu mir um wie das Meme. Wie das Meme, dann gehst du im Holzfühlerhemd wieder. Ich habe mir diese Woche einen Traum erfüllt. Und zwar hatte ich schon immer den Traum einer Körpererfahrung, ausserhalb meines Körpers. Also sich selbst zu sehen. Das ist ja manchmal, also sozusagen sich selber, ich mach's konkret, ich hatte immer schon Probleme mit den Ohren, aber nicht Probleme im Sinn, wie du es jetzt vielleicht denkst. Und zwar fand ich es immer einfach sehr stimulierend, in den Ohren rumzupulen. Mhm. Und ich hatte irgendwie ... Mit Ohrenstäbchen. Mit Ohrenstäbchen, mit allem, was gerade da war.
Und das ist ja ... Also das hat ...
Ich will nicht sagen, es geht ins Erode. pulen. Und ich hatte irgendwie Mit Ohrenstäbchen. Mit Ohrenstäbchen, mit allem, was gerade da war.
Und das ist ja, also das hat,
ich will nicht sagen, es geht ins Erotische,
aber ich meine, du kennst ja
wahrscheinlich, man kennt ja dieses
Pickel ausdrücken, Nasenpopel
rausziehen, der Mensch hat ein
gewisses Lustempfinden
bei der Selbstreinigung naheliegenderweise.
Natürlich soll es für den Körper
befriedigend sein, wenn der ganze Dreck rausgeht, ist ja klar.
Und ich habe das eben in den Ohren und das ist natürlich ganz gefährlich,
weil du, je mehr du in den Ohren rumpulst, desto mehr drückst du ja alles rein.
Der HNO-Arzt sagt ja immer wieder, bitte nichts, macht einfach gar nichts, bitte gar nichts.
Und trotzdem gibt es eine riesige Industrie an Produkten. Schaut mal auf Amazon Ohrenreinigung. Es gibt tausende Produkte dazu. Es gibt verschiedene Zangen, Spiralen, Sauger, Kerzen. Und das habe ich tatsächlich auch diese Woche erfahren. Also es gibt diese Ohrenkerzen. Ja, es gibt ein Bild von mir, wie ich so, es ist eine Winterzeit, also Weihn Weihnachtszeit entstanden, sieht man an meinen dicken Klamotten, aber ich sehe aus wie der Adventskranz, weil ich liege auf dem Boden und habe diese Kerze, die toll leuchtet, im Ohr stecken und grinst in die Kamera und ich liege in so einer stabilen Seitenlage im Wohnzimmer beim Kumpel. Und wir haben uns diese Ohrenkerzen gekauft.
Und ich sehe halt einfach wirklich aus wie ein Kerzenständer, wie ein menschlicher Kerzenständer. Viel zu grosser, unhandlicher und für die Größe auch viel zu unergiebiger Kerzenständer für nur eine Kerze. So ein Weihnachtspulli und es hat auch irgendwie alles Passe zusammen und draußen schneit es irgendwie vorm Fenster und ich liege am Boden und aus mir kommt so eine Kerze raus, die oben ganz schön leuchtet. Das ist schon besinnlich. Aber Ohrenkerzen sind ein gutes Beispiel, weil die Idee der Ohrenkerze ist ja,
dass dadurch, dass oben die Kerze brennt, ein Auftrieb, ein Unterdruck entsteht, der dann den Ohrenschmalz rausziehen kann.
Stellt sich raus, das ist von vorne bis hinten kompletter Bullshit.
Aber es ist ja dann Ohrenschmalz.
Nein, ist es nicht.
Bei mir, bei Altenweather Simon.
Das, was du gesehen hast, ist kein Ohrenschmalz, sondern Teil der Kerze. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, warte, warte, warte.
Diese Kerze, diese Flamme.
Aber waren wir auf dem Mond?
Nein, das war eine Folge Wallace and Gromit. Ja, ja, meine wir. Äh, aber warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte, warte. Diese Flamme.
Aber Elton vs. Simon hatte doch mal einmal die Challenge, wer hat mehr Ohrenschmalz? Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich an die Folge. Deswegen hat mich diese Enthüllung ja genauso schockiert. Ich habe mich ein bisschen mit diesem Ohrenthema beschäftigt. Und ich habe einen HNO-Arzt sagen hören, diese Kerze, die da brennt, hat nicht mal im Ansatz genug Kraft oder Unterdruck oder Auftrieb oder was auch immer, um Ohrenschmalz aus dem Ohr. Also das ergibt ja Sinn. Stell dir mal vor, was du für einen Druck, einen Sog brauchst und dann so eine Flamme. Ja, vor allem, was mich auch stürzig gemacht hat, damals schon als Kerzenständer, als Lebendiger, war ja, du kriegst die ja gar nicht so in dein Ohr, dass sie luftdicht abschließt. Das heißt, unabhängig von dem Druck, der schon nicht da ist, schafft es die Kerze ja gar nicht, dein Ohr komplett auszufüllen. Es hat ja unten auch nicht sowieso Airpods Aufsätze, die sich dann so einigermaßen luftdicht abschliessen. Aber wie erstaunlich ist es denn, dass es dieses Produkt gibt und man zu Hunderten auf Amazon kaufen kann, ein Produkt, das rein gar keinen Nutzen hat? Bei mir ist nichts allein an der Sendung Elton vs. Simon. Ja, und vielleicht muss ich mir Elton vs. Simon nochmal, aber ich habe auch eine Erinnerung, dass da richtig viel rauskommt. Ich weiß nicht, ob da noch mehr gemacht wird oder ob das vielleicht tatsächlich eine Art Betrug ist, dass da wirklich dann irgendwie so dieses Wachs oder was auch immer von der Kerze, das dann geschmolzen ist, einfach so aussieht. Aber rein physikalisch, so wurde es mir zumindest erklärt, ich kann das nicht nachvollziehen, kann es nicht funktionieren, weil die Kraft einfach nicht genug ist. Die, glaube ich, waren bei so einer speziellen Spa-Massage Gedöns, vielleicht haben die noch mal andere Techniken, wo es dann geht. Aber so diese klassischen Ohrenkerzen, die du dir auf Amazon kaufen kannst, können nicht funktionieren. Und das, erst mal das hat mich komplett umgehauen, dass dieses Bedürfnis Ich bin ganz, ich bin flabbergastet. Dieses Bedürfnis, Ohrenschmalz aus den Ohren zu holen, was nach medizinischem Konsens schlicht überhaupt nicht nötig ist, ist eine riesige Industrie, die sogar mit einfach mit klarem Betrug einfach Geld verdient.
Aber das Bedürfnis der Menschen muss ja so groß sein, dass sie bereit sind, sich diesem Humbug hinzugeben, weil sie so dringend den Ohrenschmalz rausziehen wollen, was wie gesagt nicht nötig ist. Wobei das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht ganz genau, weil ich war auch mal bei einem HNO damals und hatte irgendwie Schwierigkeiten mit Ohrenschmalz und der wurde dann rausgespült, Ja. Was rückblickend immer noch das befriedigendste Ereignis meines Lebens war. Ich weiß genau, was du meinst. Da hat er Wasser reingespült und plötzlich wurde es ganz heiß und mit einem Schwall kam er einfach der ganze ... Das hört sich auch so gut an. Oh, raus, säubere mich. Wenn das so aus der Tiefe kommt und das so ganz nach hinten weitergeht und sich so rauszieht, ist es fantastisch. Ja, und ich glaube, es ist dieses, ja, so Exorzismus, so alte Gedanken. Und das habe ich auch immer, wenn ich Kopfschmerzen habe zum Beispiel. Ich weiß nicht, ob es euch auch so geht, aber generell Schmerzen im Körper. Stelle ich mir immer eine große Nadel vor, so eine lange, sehr, sehr ganz kleine vom Durchmesser, aber eine ganz lange spitze Nadel,
die mir jemand, der ganz filigran
damit umgehen kann, irgendwo reinführt,
wo ich gerade den Schmerz habe und dann so
daran zieht und dann sieht man
oben in dieser Art Spritze
sieht man dann so etwas kleines Schwarzes.
Der Schmerz wird rausgesaugt.
Ich stelle mir das immer vor, diesen Schmerz als
irgendwie externen Fremdkörper,
der jetzt dann rausgezogen ist. Das habe ich bei Kopfschmerzen stelle ich mir das auch so vor, dass da irgendwo etwas in meinem Kopf drin ist, was dann rausgezogen werden kann. Und das zieht es so aus ganz vielen Adern, Ädernchen so zusammen und dann alles raus. Und dann sieht man oben in diesem kleinen, in dieser Glaskapsel sieht man dann oben dieses kleine schwarze Nebel. So ein bisschen das Gegenteil von dem, was die Dementoren bei Harry Potter, um das wieder zu bedienen, ist eine Franchise, was wir heute heranziehen, als großes Nachschlagewerk. Stell dir vor, du gehst zu deinem Haus und sagst, so ein bisschen wie das Gegenteil von den Dementoren, also dass mir der Schmerz so rausgezogen wird. Ja, ohne Augenkontakt. Ich erzähle dieses viel zu schnell, ohne Augenkontakt mit meinem Harry-Potter-Shirt, auf dem sehr viele Sabber flecken. Aber das ist, glaube ich, ein grundmenschliches Bedürfnis, so dieses vollständige Rausziehen, komplett sauber machen, so ist es alles raus, so der komplette Eiter von ganz tief drin, so rausgesaugt und so. Und das war auf jeden Fall immer ein großes Bedürfnis von mir. Und ich habe mir dann auch Videos angeschaut von einer HNO-Ärztin, die gesagt hat, es gibt ein Problem. Und zwar, wir stellen uns das Ohr als lange Röhre vor. Und ungefähr ab der Mitte beginnt überhaupt erst Ohrenschmalz. Von der Mitte und der Ohrenschmalz kommt in der Mitte der Röhre raus und wird dann nach außen geleitet. Also da ist es wie so eine Rolltreppe. So eine Rolltreppe, die von der Mitte der Röhre nach draußen immer wieder den Ohrenschmalz rausdrückt.
Wenn man jetzt aber mit einem Stiel oder Stab oder Zange oder irgendwas da reindrückt und den Schmalz hinter diesen Punkt drückt, wo das Ohrenschmalz überhaupt entsteht, dann kommt es gar nicht mehr raus. Weil es keinen Mechanismus gibt, der das nach draussen drtreppe, genau, du stehst vor der Rolltreppe und kommst nie wieder in diesen Mechanismus rein, dass du rausgeführt wirst. Wie funktioniert diese Rolltreppe? Also ich bediene mich jetzt dem sehr effektiven Wort Drüse. Also auch, das muss reichen. Das Wort Drüse muss jetzt re. Weil da ist eine Kraftreiche... Ich stelle mir jetzt mich vor, wie denn, wie so ein Darm, als ob unser Ohr wie so ein Darm ist, der das so rausdrückt. So rausdrückt? Ja, wie so eine Schlange. Wie wenn man es schluckt, dass es dann so runtergedrückt wird. Ja, oder schluckt. Ja. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es funktioniert. Welche Kräfte da wirken, weiss ich auch nicht. Ich denke mir, der Zentrifugalkräfte. Also wenn du die Ohren schluckst zum Beispiel. Eher akzeptiert als Drüsel. Aber die Kräfte rein wirken ja wenig. Aber raus ja immer, wenn du dich bewegst. Okay. Das heißt, das ist ein Problem. Aber das könnte ja bei mir vorliegen. Hundertprozentig, ja. Und da muss ein HNO-Arzt eingreifen, weil das kommt nicht mehr normal raus. Und wenn du jetzt als Laie da anfängst rumzupopeln, schiebst du es eher noch tiefer rein. Und dann kann es symptomatisch werden, heisst irgendwie Schmerzen oder du hörst weniger, es hört sich dumpf an, Druck oder was auch immer. Und dann ist da einfach nur Ohrenschmalz drin. So, jetzt sagte ich mir natürlich, ja dann gehe ich zum Arzt. Oder. HM.-O-der.
Ich erfülle mir einen lang gehegten Traum.
Denn mein Traum war es immer, mir selbst ins Ohr schauen zu können.
Also selbst sehen zu können, was da überhaupt drin ist und wie man es rauskriegt. Weil das grosse Problem ist ja, dass man es nicht sieht.
Nein, nein, nein, bitte nicht. Hast du dir so einen Ohrenkatheter gekauft? Nein, eine ganz kleine Kamera? Ich habe mir bestellt. Oh mein Gott, dann machst du doch alles noch viel schlimmer. Ich habe mir ein Otoskop bestellt. Und jetzt Achtung, dicker Disclaimer. Ich habe keine Ahnung von Medizin, ich bin kein Arzt. Wenn ihr irgendwelche medizinischen Schwierigkeiten habt, geht zum Arzt. Einfach geht zum Arzt, Punkt. Sind wir jetzt so ein Podcast, der wie so Jackass so, wir sind berühmte ausgebildete Stuntmänner und nicht nachmachen, was wir machen, Disclaimer haushauen müssen? Ich will nur, dass das im richtigen Kontext ist, weil ich habe dann mal recherchiert und gegoogelt. Ich bin klar, dass du kein Arzt bist, ab jetzt werdest. Weil ich habe mal recherchiert und gegoogelt und dann dachte ich mir, okay, du gehst jetzt in den alten Sumpf wieder, diese alten tausenden verschiedenen Produkte. Dann habe ich aber tatsächlich gesehen, dass es das gibt. Drahtlose Kamera mit Lampe. Drahtlos. Drahtlos, die man sich ins Ohr stecken kann.
Wenn ich bei einer Sache ein Draht akzeptieren kann, dann ist es diese Kamera. Für 20 Euro. Es gibt drahtlose Kameras, die werden doch locker immer zu spionale Shit benutzt. Und natürlich, dein Instinkt ist goldrichtig. Das ist Müll, das ist billig produziert, das funktioniert nicht, das ist schäbig, das ist schlecht verarbeitet, das funktioniert nicht. Die Idee klingt gut. Du verbindest diese Kamera mit deinem Handy und auf deinem Handy wird dann das Bild der Kamera angezeigt, das du dir selber ins Ohr schiebst. Und ich dachte mir, das wird nicht klappen. Ich kenne ja die Branche. Ich kenne doch die Ohrenentfernungsbranche. Wir erinnern uns an die Ohrenkerzen. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Aber vielleicht doch. Also habe ich an einem ... And that was the moment you hit by. Also habe ich es bestellt. Oh mein Gott. Und heute kam es an. Ich habe es heute aus der Packstation geholt, konnte es natürlich nicht erwarten, pack diese Kamera aus, schliesse sie an, über WLAN wird es verbunden mit dem Handy, klappt einwandfrei und es ist das Beste, was ich mir je bestellt habe. Das glaube ich jetzt nicht. Es ist unfassbar gut. Aber die Kamera ist richtig gut. Warum reagierst du auf, führ dir nicht ins Ohr ein, mit, ich führe mir maximal viel ins Ohr ein, nämlich, literally eine Kamera, fick dich, Hals, Nasen, Ohren, Ärztin, die ich bei YouTube gefunden habe, die mich eigentlich sehr beruhigt hat, dass ihr das Gegenteil erreicht mit ihrer Speech. Das Ding ist, ich wollte, ich dachte mir, nachschauen, schadet mich. Wenn ich jetzt sehe, da ist, das kriege ich nicht, das ist irgendwie, da ist alles vollgestopft, dann kann ich ja immer noch zum HNO-Arzt gehen. Ich will aber nicht der sein, der da auftaucht und dann sagt, mein Ohr ist verstopft und dann schaut er rein und so, nee, alles wunderbar, ciao. Auch das ist kein Problem, geht zum HNO-Arzt, das ist kein Problem. Auch eine Nichtdiagnose hilft euch. Aber ich dachte, wenn ich nicht zum HNO-Arzt gehen will, muss ich selber zum HNO-Arzt gehen. Und ich sag's euch und ich will jetzt wirklich hier keine Werbung machen, aber dieses Produkt ist einfach fantastisch. Aber ist es ausschließlich für Ohren oder? Nein. Was heißt ein Orthoskop übersetzt? Autoskop heißt lang, Stielkamera für deine Körper. So in der Richtung. Es ist eine 1080p-Kamera, die automatisch scharf stellt, es ist eine winzig kleine Linse mit einer Lampe dran und du siehst wirklich alles. Alleine mal sein Ohr zu sehen, unabhängig von allem anderen,
sind locker 20 Euro wert.
Weil letzten Endes der Mensch sucht Abenteuer und Aufregung,
aber das Aufregendste ist doch letzten Endes noch der eigene Körper.
Und ich habe mir heute in die Nase geschaut,
ich habe mir in den Mund geschaut, in die Ohren geschaut, allein das medizinische Interesse.
Was ist das Weirdeste, was du gefunden hast in deinem Körper? Naja, also ich habe, sage ich mal, meine Schlüssel wiedergefunden. Also so ein Legostein. Aber Moment, ein Ottoskop finde ich jetzt hier, ist von Altgriechisch Ohr und Betr heißt es auch Ohr, ja, Otto. Ist ein Gerät des HNO-Arztes und des Hörgeräts der Kursikers zur Betrachtung, Untersuchung. Das ist dieses Gerät, was man kennt, was die einem reinstecken ins Ohr. Aber du hast jetzt nicht so eine lange Kamera, wo du tief in dein Ohr reinkommst. Also sie ist nicht wirklich lang, aber du kommst halt schon. Also ich habe mich noch nicht getraut, richtig tief reinzugehen. Weil ab einem gewissen Punkt wird es auch einfach schon ein bisschen gruselig, weil klar, man hört immer wieder in den Medien Trommelfell, Trommelfell, Trommelfell, ja, aber was, was zur Hölle genau das ist und wie das aussieht, weiss kein Mensch. Also ich würde auch das nicht erkennen, wenn ich sehe. Eine Wand. Ja, aber das ist ja schon eine Art von, ich stelle es mir vor wie so ein Trommelaufzug, so ein Trommelfell. Das ist eine Wand. Das ist einfach eine Wand. Heissen die auch Trommelfell bei Trommeln? Ja, das sind Fälle. Ah ja, okay. So, und da dachte ich mir, und jetzt nur mal ganz kurz für dich, also wird das ein bisschen grafisch, aber hier ist ein Bild, nicht von mir, aber so sieht das aus. Das ist die Qualität, mit der wir arbeiten. Es ist ja Wahnsinn, also wir sehen ein fotorealistisches, es war einmal das Leben, kennst du noch diese Serie? Es ist ja ein fotorealistisches Bild, aber jetzt... Das ist die Kameraaufnahme, das ist die Kameraaufnahme. Irre, es ist insanely gut. Es ist wirklich unfassbar. Was für gute Bilder. Und also das auch mit automatischer Scharfstellung. Und in der App kannst du sogar auch angeben, rechtes Ohr, linkes Ohr, damit das das irgendwie anders darstellt oder du das besser steuern kannst oder was auch immer. Es ist also allein vom Technikverständnis her für so wenig Geld. Und es ist drahtlos, Leute. Falls ihr es Leuten zeigen wollt, die im Nebenraum sitzen, aber ihr wollt nicht gerne das vor denen machen, zum Beispiel, könnt ihr das drahtlos bei euch im Badezimmer machen. Falls ihr eine lange Zugfahrt vor euch habt, ja, kein Problem, Ruheabteil und schön rein ins Ohr. Und auch hier, ihr könnt das Handy anderen Leuten geben, weil es ist nämlich drahtlos. Ist doch spannend, jemand anders gibt euch die Anweisungen und ihr müsst euch selber im Ohr rumfuhlen. Macht doch Spaß, so kriegt man doch mal die Reise rum nach Stuttgart. Aber das sind so Dinge, wo ich dann denke, die Welt ist Fakt, ist einfach, wir sind alle verloren. Ja. Ist der Fakt, dass da drin, dass das drahtlos ist? Weil offensichtlich ist inzwischen das Drahtlos zu produzieren fast billiger. Ja. Es ist etwas, was nicht drahtlos sein muss. Und ich liebe alles daran, dass es drahtlos ist. Es ist ein lächerlich, vor allem die Erwartungshaltung wurde so bombastisch übertroffen. Ich dachte, das ist halt kompletter Plastik-Schrott-Crab, das bringt nichts. Kameras sind im Tisch nicht mehr so teuer. Es ist unglaublich, aber man denkt sich ja auch, klar, stell dir mal vor, welche Möglichkeiten hatten Ärzte vor zehn Jahren, die kannst du dir heute leisten wahrscheinlich. Immer zehn Jahre später kannst du dir State of the Art leisten und kannst deinen eigenen Kernspintomographen irgendwann zu Hause, einfach eine App so. Aber also das war schon krass. Ich habe einen drahtlosen Kernspintomographen zu Hause, ich mussbe zu Hause. Aber okay, das Bild, was du nämlich gezeigt hast, zeigt einem ja die Unordnung, die in unseren Ohren halt nun mal so herrscht. Ja, es ist wirklich widerlich. Es ist das, genau. Es ist wirklich widerlich, weil du hast ja keine Ahnung. Das führt doch jetzt dazu, dass du das, du bist ja jetzt noch tiefer in deinen Rabbit Hole gestiegen. Ja, ja. Weil du hast jetzt Dinge in deinem Ohr gesehen, die du da nicht rausbekommst. Aber das Gute ist, du siehst, was los ist. Weil den grössten Schaden richtest du ja dadurch an, dass du da einfach rumpulst, wildkürlich, und dann die Inhäute, die ja auch nichts aushalten, weil warum sollen sie irgendwas aushalten? So ein Trommelfälle. Ja, auch das weiß ich nicht, aber haltest du die Haut und dann kratzt du da rum. Also ich meine, über Millionen Jahre Evolution war da einfach nichts drin. Maximum war der kleine Finger. Und jetzt kommst du da mit Metallinstrumenten. Natürlich kriegen die das nicht hin. Natürlich sagen die Aua, Aua, Aua, Aua, bitte, ich bin dafür nicht gemacht, ich kann nichts dagegen tun. Und also ich bin jetzt drin, ich fühle mich meinem Körper jetzt näher, es ist wirklich ausserordentlich ekelhaft, es ist wirklich ekelhaft, aber ich glaube, man macht einen ähnlichen Weg durch wie ein Arzt auch, es ist erstmal ekelhaft, aber nach zehn, zwanzig Minuten distanzierst du. Also dein Tag war heute, dass du dir mindestens, wir haben noch nicht, und man beschönigt ja auch hier, man weiß ja, man redet vor einem Publikum, das heißt, du hastestens 20 Minuten hat er mit verbracht, dir in deinen Ohren herumzureisen. Absolut, es ist so nach 10, 20 Minuten. Urlaub zu Hause. Man verliert irgendwann den Kontakt zu sich selbst. Man denkt, man arbeitet an einem Patienten oder so, man arbeitet irgendwo. Und du realisierst gar nicht mehr, dass das an dir selber ist. Ich habe ab dem gewissen Punkt gesagt, so tief und nicht tiefer, weil ich mir gesagt habe, ich will es nicht der Trottel sein, der zum HNO-Arzt geht und eine Kamera im Ohr stecken hat und ihn nicht mehr rauskriegt. Weil sie, und hier ist das Problem, drahtlos ist. Und ich kann mir nur das Lächeln des HNO-Arztes vorstellen, der sagt, aha, sie wollten also selber mal Arzt spielen und haben sich so ein Schrottteil gekauft und jetzt muss ich Ihnen das aus dem Ohr ziehen.
Nee, die sind so entspannt wie bei mir, nämlich bei dem Rollerunfall und sagen, ah ja gut, seitdem es diese Geräte gibt, gibt es die Patienten dafür. Weil ich kann es genau vorstellen, seitdem es diese Geräte gibt, gibt es die Patienten dafür, weil Leute sich das ins Ohr stecken. Und du musst auch noch Werbung jetzt dafür. Oder es gibt weniger Patienten, weil tatsächlich das Problem ist, ich sehe halt, was da ist, aber ich kann es halt nicht interpretieren.
Also der Arzt hat ja nicht nur den technischen Vorsprung, sondern der hat ja, der weiß ja auch, was los ist. Also ich kann jetzt auch sehen, aber ich weiß halt nicht, was es ist.
Du hast eine Röntgenmaschine gekauft, die kein, nicht lesbar, also du machst viele tolle, tolle Bilder.
Kannst du mal so ein Mini-Gif hochladen von so den Highlights irgendwie?
Ich habe heute schon echt was rausgeholt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Vor allem ist das auch, also du hast ja... Ja, aber kannst du mal so ein Mini-Gif mal hochladen von so den Highlights irgendwie?
Oh, ich habe heute schon echt was rausgeholt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Vor allem ist das auch, also du hast ja dann die Kamera und ein bisschen wie so ein Ego-Shooter, wo du so immer unten in der Mitte die Waffe hast, hast du unten in der Mitte diesen Schaber. Und du kannst dann mit der Kamera ... Du kannst auch schaben? Ja klar, ja klar. Du hast so einen blauen Schaber, der immer vorne an der Kamera ist und du kannst dann damit wirklich wie ein Ego-Shooter kannst du damit dann rangehen. Das sind merkwürdige Gefühle, weil das sind teilweise Körperbereiche, wo man wahrscheinlich noch nie berührt wurde und noch nie so zärtlich. Wir reden schon von einem Ohrenschmalzentferner. Korrekt? Das ist schon genau dafür gemacht. Ich dachte, okay, ich dachte, du bist jetzt von ... Ich will mir das rausholen. Bist du jetzt bei ...
Ich guck mir erst mal an, was die Situation aussieht, aber es ist ja immer noch ein Ohrenschmalz entferner. Es ist ein Ohrenschmalz entferner mit Kamera.
Allein die Tatsache, dass es jemanden gibt, der dieses Produkt entwickelt hat und das sich ja anscheinend auch verkauft, und das hat 2000 Bewertungen, also wie viele Leute müssen es gekauft haben, weil der Mensch diesen Drang hat, sich selbst zu entohren, einfach diese Ohrenschmalz raus. Zu reinigen ja erstmal in allen Belangen. Ja. Es ist verrückt und ich werde wahrscheinlich jetzt, ihr könnt euch das wahrscheinlich vorstellen, wie das weitergeht, jede Woche ein bisschen tiefer rein, weil irgendwann will ich schon mal das Trommelfeld sehen. Vielleicht schaue ich mir davor ein Video an, wo mal jemand beschreibt, wie das aussieht, damit ich weiß, womit ich zu tun habe.
Aber letzten Endes, warum kann man denn nicht sein eigener Arzt sein?
Bis zu einem gewissen Punkt.
Naja, Bildung, Ausbildung.
Okay, sag mir noch einen Grund.
Neutrale Personen können dich besser bewerten als du dich selber, ausserkörperlich.
Noch einen.
Das, nee, ich habe nur zwei. Okay, naja, gulich. Noch einen? Das, ähm,
nee, ich hab nur zwei. Okay, naja, guck mal,
schau mal, da sind wir doch schon gar nicht weit.
Ich find's auch zu cool, ehrlich gesagt, dafür.
Ich mein, klar, natürlich kann man sich nicht selber
irgendwie schwere Krankheiten heilen,
aber da mal reingehen, ich mein, wir alle wissen, wie das endet.
Nächstes Vorsicht mit einem riesigen Verband
um die Ohren.
Ja, oder mit einer Mittelohrentzündung,
das kann ich mir eher vorstellen, weil du hast es ja nicht vorher desinfiziert. Naja, Wasser abgespielt. Du hast es aus deinem, ja, wie gesagt, du hast es nicht desinfiziert, du hast es aus deinem Amazon-Paket gekramt. Ich habe tatsächlich Handdesinfektion, hat ja jetzt mittlerweile jeder zu Hause, praktisch, jetzt kann auch jeder Arzt sein, weil jetzt haben wir alles, was Ärzte auch haben, winzige Kameras und Desinfektionsmittel. Und jetzt hält uns niemand mehr auf. Und es ist ja schon spannend. Ich habe dann auch in die Nase reingeschaut und den Mund und so. Das ist schon verrückt. In der Reihenfolge. Ohren, Nase, Mund. Ja, von oben nach unten. Und da habe ich auch aufgehört beim Mund. Weil da wird es dann zu eklig. Und da kann man dann auch so mal sich die Zähne angucken. Irgendwas ist da drin. Das ist schon alles ein bisschen ekelhaft. Aber Mund ist schwer, weil das beschlägt auch manchmal. Aber gut, da muss man dann natürlich... Das heißt, du bist so weit weg, einen Arzttermin zu vereinbaren. Du bist so weit davon weg, dass du lieber dir das Gerät, was der Arzt dafür benutzen würde, selber kaufst. Es ist Next Level introvertiert sein. Aber ab jetzt versuche ich, alles erstmal zu lösen und hier nochmal dick der Disclaimer, ihr solltet das nicht machen, ihr geht zum Arzt, kein Problem. Ich bin das Negativbeispiel, aber vielleicht kann man sich den ein oder anderen Arztbesuch auch sparen. Wahnsinn. Es ist wirklich, also es ist unglaublich. Die Kamera ist fantastisch. Ich finde das ganz, ganz toll. Man sieht es und es ist sehrend. Und es ist einfach krass. Ich finde es toll, dass es jemand macht, den ich kenne. Ich finde es beunruhigend, dass wir auf eine Art auch beruflich aufeinander angewiesen sind und du jetzt anfängst, dir Dinge zu kaufen und dir die in die Körperöffnung zu stecken. Ja. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich aber jetzt mal so rein wissenschaftlich sehr davon angetan, zu gucken, wie die Storyline weitergeht. Weil ich sage dir wirklich, bestimmt seit 15 Jahren habe ich diesen Traum, mir selber in die Ohren zu schauen zu können. Und jetzt kann ich so. Und klar, natürlich wir erinnern uns an dem, was ich vorhin gesagt habe, man muss es nicht entfernen. Meine Frage ist natürlich die, die du auch gestellt hast, was macht man mit dem Ohrenschmalz, der hinter diesem Äquator liegt? Komme ich so tief, komme ich da überhaupt ran? Der ist ja nicht gekennzeichnet, da ist ja nicht ein Strich, der sagt, und hier bitte nicht weitergehen, sondern das ist ein Ohr. Und deswegen Punkt eins, Ärzte sind besser ausgebildet, wahrscheinlich könnten die dir das besser entfernen. Ja, und also ich schaue jetzt mal wie tief ich komme und ich werde mir natürlich, also ich meine, ich sag mal so, ich kann mir das ja auch so ein bisschen andenken. Ich habe ja nur ich verstehe, dass ein Arzt viel Dinge lernen muss, weil der den ganzen Körper abdecken muss. Aber du hast nur ein Problem. Ich habe nur ein ganz spezielles Problem. HNOs müssen genau, die müssen nicht den ganzen Körper abdecken. Das kommst du selber drauf. Ja, okay, aber die haben trotzdem noch, also für mich ist auch schon die Tatsache, dass das Ohr zusammen mit zwei anderen Körperteilen zusammengeworfen wird, kann es nicht so komplex sein.
Ja, verstehe ich genau, was du meinst.
Also, wie schwer kann es sein? Das ist ein Drittel Studium und dann kannst du dich spezialisieren.
Ja, wohingegen Kardiologie oder Onkologie, alles, das scheint schon komplexer zu sein, das ist nur eine Sache.
Ja, und es sind auch nicht so viele, aber HNOs, wie mein. Schau mal vor, du bist so gut, dass du nur O bist. Ich bin O-Arzt. Oh ja, weil ich habe mich so darauf spezialisiert und ich weiss so viel darüber. Es ist lächerlich, was für ein Experte ich auf dem Thema bin, dass ich nur O-Arzt sein muss. Das ist doch wie bei Pokémon, dass die alle so ein Element haben, das sie besonders gut haben.
Und eigentlich müsste es so eine Datenbank geben, so wer hat Schwäche O, wer hat Stärke H, Resistenz N und sowas.
Ich will so ein Dreieck, gibt es ja bei Videospielen manchmal so die Kompetenzen im Dreieck angeordnet.
Bei dir ging es ja diese Woche eher in Richtung A.
Ja genau, ich habe mir nämlich auch einen Traum erfüllt, denn ich habe mir endlich mal geleistet, was ich schon vielleicht hätte eher machen sollen, weil ich habe aufgehört, eine Brille zu tragen. In der Corona-Zeit hat mich das irgendwann sehr genervt mit der Maske und das es anderen beschlägt und generell war ich nie ein großer Fan von der Brille. Ich meine, das ist jedem selber belassen und ich finde Brillen auch nicht besonders schlimm oder so und optisch bei anderen Menschen finde ich es auch manchmal total cool und es soll jeder selber entscheiden, auch hier der Disclaimer, aber ich habe mich nicht mehr so richtig wohl damit gefühlt, auch wie es für mich immer so ein bisschen so eine Distanz zur Umwelt war. Man muss immer was ablegen beim Sport und so, ist nie geil, für mich. Und ich fand es auch für mich immer nicht so richtig cool ästhetisch und habe dann irgendwann aufgehört das zu tragen habe angefangen Kontaktlinsen zu tragen zu einem Grad der nicht mehr gesund war weil ich so oft Kontaktlinsen drin hatte und es ist auch nervig so und jetzt beginnt deine persönliche Horrorgeschichte glaube ich Deckwelt ich habe mich dann jetzt überlegt ich möchte gerne meine Augen lasern lassen weil das ist so eine gängzwischen, dieses Lasek-Verfahren, irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein paar Millionen Mal schon gemacht worden inzwischen in Deutschland. Und es ist wirklich wahnsinnig gängig, gibt es irgendwie seit 20 Jahren. Moment, aber zählt man da zweimal pro Patient wegen Augen, oder? Das ist eine gute Frage. Also wenn du sagst, eine Million Mal gemacht, eine Million Patienten. Es ist auch kein wissenschaftlicher Podcast, die ganzen Zahlen, die sind mit einem riesengroßen Sternchen. Bis jetzt hatten wir ein gutes Niveau, du ziehst es gerade ein bisschen runter. Ne, ich weiß nicht, die ganze genaue Anzahl weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber auf jeden Fall wurde es unglaublich häufig gemacht, gibt es schon super lange diese Methode und ja, ich meine, wenn man generell operiert wird, davor kriegt man ja immer so einen Aufklärungsbogen, wo viele Sachen und viele Horrorszenarien aufgemalt sind. Der Fakt, so ein Pirat, worst case, so ein Sauron. Aber das genau, ich sag mal, das sieht man an dem Aufklärungsbogen, sieht man schon, ah krass, ein ganz schön standardmäßiges Verfahren inzwischen. Also man darf laut Gesetzgeber am nächsten Tag schon wieder Auto fahren, etc. Und es ist auch ein. Es ist auch ein Drive-Thru. Es ist einfach ein Drive-Thru. Es ist als Achterbahn sogar, damit es ein bisschen lustiger ist. Du hast was gemacht. Ich habe es gestern gemacht. Du hast gestern eine Operation gehabt, hast wahrscheinlich viel damit erlebt, war eine Extremsituation für dich. Das Erste, was mir dabei einfällt, ist, bin ich selbst. Und zwar, du hast ja geschrieben, ich habe die OP, wir können nicht aufnehmen. Hättest du es gut gefunden, wenn ich da so etwas geschrieben hätte wie alles Gute für die Operation? Weil ich habe überlegt, weil wenn diese Operation etwas total Normales ist und ich dann aber, also womit kann ich dir mehr Angst nehmen, wenn ich dir so etwas schreibe wie, hey, alles Gute für die OP wird schon klappen oder indem ich einfach sage, okay, cool, dann sehen wir uns ja am Tag danach, also dass ich es total runterspiele.
Hättest du dir jetzt rückblickend gewünscht, dass ich sowas schreibe wie viel Glück bei der OP, wird schon schief gehen oder nicht? Nee, ich find's gut, wie du es gemacht hast.
Okay.
Also wenn du geschrieben hättest, ich glaube, du wärst der Einzige, der mir so richtig Angst gemacht hätte, wenn du geschrieben hast, am Tag davor nochmal irgendwie so, Herr Stefan, ich wollte nochmal sagen, viel Erfolg morgen, egal wie es ausgeht, wir hatten eine schöne Zeit und ich hab dich so gern, egal was passiert, wir kriegen das zusammen hin, also so sehr viel impliziert wäre auch, ich glaube, du von allen Leuten wärst noch der, der mir am meisten Angst hätte machen können. Bei dir bin ich sehr froh, dass du nichts geschrieben hast. Ich habe niemanden jetzt bei der Operation gebraucht, der mir sagt, viel Glück, viel Erfolg. Meine Mutter war sehr, sehr angsteinflössend supportive und war dann so, ich hole dich da ab auch und so was. Das fand ich dann schon teilweise so, okay, es ist schon eine Operation. Also natürlich, je nett gemeinter das dann immer ist, die Gestiken und die Handlungen etc., desto mehr denkt man auch darüber nach, ui, was tue ich mir gerade eigentlich an, zumal es ja unbedrängt ist. Ich hätte ja auch mit Kontaktlinsen slash Brille weiter gut leben können. Und was für Vorwürfe macht man sich denn eigentlich, wenn unbedrängt plötzlich beide Augen blind sind? Was aber nicht, es ist schon eine Option, es kann passieren, dann aber eher durch die Infektion danach oder sowas. Also ich glaube, es ist so ein sicheres Verfahren, da macht man nichts falsch. Das Verfahren an sich war dann aber tatsächlich viel, viel schlimmer als gedacht. Ich kam hin, ich wusste ja genau, was passiert, haben die mir gut erklärt. Und vorher machen die alle Messungen und so, das war alles ganz durchsichtig und verständlich.
Man kommt nur da hin und dann wird schon gefragt, ob man eine Berührungstablette möchte. Jetzt schon! Jetzt habe ich Angst, wenn sie mich das fragen. Und ich habe gesagt, ich würde super gerne so eine Tablette haben, einfach mal, um es mal zu probieren. Also so eine Berührungstablette, wahnsinnig cool, also generell, mal auszuprobieren, finde ich total spannend. Hättest du die denn nehmen können und einstecken können, oder wäre das so, wie müssen Sie die jetzt auch schon nehmen? Das war meine implizierte Frage. Ich habe gesagt, ich brauche das gerade nicht, mir geht es gut, ich bin da nicht nervös vor, und ich will auch heute konkret, will ich das jetzt nicht nehmen. Dann ist der ganze Tag, ist man dann irgendwie, dann soll man keine wichtigen Entscheidungen treffen etc. Gestern habe ich jetzt auch keine grossen Entscheidungen getroffen. Du hattest noch eine wichtige Entscheidung vor dir. Aber man weiß ja nicht, aber man weiß ja manchmal nicht, welche grossen Entscheidungen in uns Haus flattern. Da habe ich gedacht. Okay, okay. Und ich würde es lieber an einem anderen Tag haben. Du hättest rein theoretisch so den Mund aufmachen können und dann so, aber dann währenddessen mit der Hand die Tablette wegstecken. Und du hättest es so in der Wange gespeichert. Ja genau, dann merke ich so, die löst sich so super schnell auf. Und dann fangt die Sekretär und so, mach meinen Mund auf. Naja, da habe ich sie jedenfalls abgelehnt. Abgelehnt? Das ist ärgerlich, weil ich dann, da dachte ich mir schon, okay, dann wurde ich nervös, weil dann habe ich gedacht, wow, wahrscheinlich gehen hier alle mit dieser Berührungslibertäre rein. Ich bin der einzige Trottel, der dann sagt, nee, danke schön, brauche ich nicht, dieses tolle, von Wissenschaftlern erdachte Wundermittel der Natur, wo man keine wichtigen Scheinthauern treffen kann, weil man so wahnsinnig happy und gelöst ist. Das ist aber auch psychologisch unklug, oder? Jemanden vor der Behandlung zu fragen, ob er eine Beruhigungsstilette will. Also ich meine, das macht doch einem eher Angst. Wenn man merkt, okay, der hat Panik, dann gibt man ihm das. Oder vielleicht hast du auch so gewirkt. Nee, ich habe überhaupt nicht so gewirkt. Ich habe wahnsinnig gelöst. Er hat auch sogar gefragt, sie brauchen aber keine Brustwette, oder? Ich habe so eine standardmäßige Frage.
Vor allem, auf welcher Grundlage soll man das entscheiden? Bin ich denn überdurchschnittlich
ruhig oder bin ich überdurchschnittlich
unruhig? Er meinte, manche Leute haben wahnsinnig,
ich habe mich auch gefragt, ich habe jetzt auch keine Referenz, wie sich andere
Leute fühlen, wer nimmt denn eine? Und dann meinte er,
nee, sie brauchen keine.
Sie liegen
noch nicht schreiend am Boden. Ja,
ich glaube, Leute kommen da richtig zitternd rein.
Sie können das noch reflektieren. Es kommen Leute zitternd und angsteinflösend rein. Und dann geht man dem was. Ich wäre das. Alles, was mit Augen zu tun hat, dann kann ich die Nacht davor nicht schlafen. Was ich erlebt habe gestern, ich bin, also ich habe noch nie so unangenehm, wurde ich glaube ich angefasst. Naja, dann kommt man da rein, dann kriegt man so verschiedene Salben, also Jod ums Auge und so, damit alles desinfiziert ist und nichts reinkommt. Maske auf, wird dann noch festgeklebt und so weiter. Dann kriegt man so eine Haube auf, damit keine Haare im Gesicht hängen und zieht sich so einen lustigen OP-Mantel an. Ziemlich cool, oder? So eine Maske und Haube. Alles richtig cool, und dann legt man sich hin.
Und da drüber ist dieser Laser, der wird dann über dich gefahren, Arzt ist nett, hört man, man ist die ganze Zeit am Start, man ist die ganze Zeit komplett bei Bewusstsein. So, was jetzt gemacht wird, ist, Florin, reiss dich kurz zusammen, okay? Kann ich mich hinlegen? Was, leg dich kurz hin, okay? Ja, okay. Also, was gemacht wird, ist, ich dachte, naiverweise, Laser, weil ich bin kurzsichtig gewesen. Ihr hört schon, ein Spoiler, wahrscheinlich geht es gut aus. Also entspannt. Ich bin kurzsichtig gewesen, heisst, ich habe zu viel Hornhaut. Zu viel Hornhaut und dann kann es einfach weggelasert werden auf die richtige Länge, die man braucht, und dann ist gut. Kurzsichtigkeit heißt, dass die Hornhaut immer weiter gewachsen ist. Soll es nicht. Weitsichtigkeit kann man damit auch beheben, das ist zu wenig Hornhaut. Da macht man dann zwei andere, dann lasert man links und rechts ein bisschen was weg und dadurch biegt sich dann irgendwie die Linse wie auch immer und dann kann man den gleichen Effekt erzielen.
Bei Kurzigkeiten ist es viel einfacher, man macht es einfach weg und kürzt ein bisschen was und dann kann man gut sehen. Das heißt, ich dachte einfach, ich lege mich unter dieses Ding, dann kommt ein Laser, der macht mir das weg und ich kann nach Hause gehen. Nein, was passiert ist, die schneiden dir dein Auge auf, die nehmen ein Messer, gefühlt, es ist alles automatisiert, aber die schneiden dir einen Halbmond in dein Auge, klappen das auf und alles, während du das siehst und wach bist. Wie siehst? Nee, du siehst ja, dass jemand dir gerade dein Auge aufklappt. Aber doch nicht scharf, oder? Das ist doch dann ein bisschen verschwommen. Alles wird und verschwommen und ekelig. Und dann kommt der, und dann, es passiert. Und was konkret passiert ist, du liegst da drunter, dann macht er dir Betäubungstropfen in deine Augen, dann spürst du nichts mehr. Dann kriegst du diese Clockwork Orange, diese Augenaufhalte Dings, kriegst du rein, so eine Zange, die hält dein Auge auf. Und was dann passiert, ist das Schlimmste der ganzen Welt. Und ich dachte wirklich, ich muss mich übergeben. Man kriegt dann so einen Saugnapf aufs Auge gesetzt. Und dann sagt der, so jetzt sitzt es ein unangenehm, und es wird ein bisschen unangenehm, weil dann kommt ein Vakuum, so ein Unterdruck, und der saugt dein Auge an. Raus, oder? Es saugt dir das so fest an auf dein Auge. Oh, Gott, das will. Und das ist so eklig und so schlimm. Das ist so schlimm. Und dann kommt so ein Ding, was er dann das Auge aufschneidet, dann klappt er das selber hoch, dann kommt und dann sagt er so, jetzt kommt der Laserteil, war der entspannte Teil. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es Laserkorrektur heisst, weil das ist der ganz kleine Teil. Ja, einfach Augenmetzgerei.
Augenmetzgerei-Korrektur sollte es heissen.
Und dann kam, mein rechtes Auge war ein bisschen schwächer als mein linkes, sechs Sekunden der Laser auf mein rechtes Auge, fünf Sekunden auf mein linkes und dann war vorbei und dann plötzlich kommt der Laser, er hat gesagt, jetzt müssen Sie kurz stillhalten, da habe ich mir auch so es ist eine Option, dass ich, wenn ich jetzt meinen Kopf leicht bewege, alles, aber ich glaube, das ist alles sehr automatisiert, ist so hochpräzise. Ich glaube, man unterschätzt das dann ein bisschen auch. Und dann kam dieser Laser für sechs Sekunden und es stieg so ein verbrannter Fleischgeruch in meine Nase. Und ich dachte, ich habe einen Schlaganfall. Ich hatte nicht einen Schlaganfall. Aber er hat das angesprochen, der Arzt hat gesagt, ah, rieche ich nur ich das? Und er hat das aber so gesagt hat das aber so gesagt, als ob es nicht häufig passiert, was mir umgehebe. Er hat gesagt, riechen Sie das gerade auch? Ja, er hat gesagt, rieche ich das nur gerade oder riechen Sie das auch? Und da habe ich gesagt, Moment mal, riechen Sie das nicht immer beide oder alle in diesem Raum gerade? Und er meinte, ich so, ja, ist das nicht normal? Und er so, doch, doch, das ist normal. Ich wollte nur fragen, ob Sie es geraten haben. Ja, formulier es anders. Ja, formulier es anders. Ja, jedenfalls, ich habe mir das anders vorgestellt, weil ich dachte, wenn das weggelasert wird, weiss er nicht, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe, aber nicht, dass es so klischee-mäßig, einfach ein verbrannter Geruch, so ein verbrannter Fleischgeruch in die Nase steigt, mega weird, auch unangenehm für den Arzt, der das jedes Mal dann riechen muss. Naja, hat die Außenhand an die Stirn gelegt, wie jemand,
der gleich in so alten Filmen
im Verbindevern weht oder so.
Aber
und dann kam noch das zweite
Auge, Gott, das ist ja das
Schlimmste der Welt.
Dass du weißt, du hast das nochmal.
Wie viele Patienten brechen das
nach dem ersten Auge ab und sagen, weißt du was, wir beenden das hier, ich gehe nach Hause. Aber ich weiß nicht. Ach du meine Güte. Ich glaube ja, dass wir bei Augen so ein bisschen übersensibel. Ich bin durch dich sowieso schon geschädigt, weil du bei Augen so weird bist. Aber ich bin ja auch bei Augen dann weird. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, man ist da geschädigt. Ich glaube, das sind einfach auch, die sind so, man thront die so auf so einen Sockel und man denkt, das ist so. Ja, weil man halt ganz gern sieht, ne? Ja, aber den Mund. Weil man die Glötzlerchen halt braucht. Ja, aber in deine Ohren steckst du eine Kamera, die du aus bei Amazon gekauft hast, mit 20 Euro rein. Ja, das ist egal. Nee, du weißt, was ich meine. Ja, total. Du bist viel weniger zimperlich mit deiner Nase, mit deinem München. Aber deine Äuglein, die sind dann plötzlich so unantastbar. Ja, weil diese Glupsch-Dinger sind. Wo man denkt, wenn man da mit einer Nadel drankommt, dann laufen die aus. Man weiß ja nicht, worauf die bestehen und so einen Scheiß. Brr, ach, ey. Und dann war es super schnell vorbei. Die ganze Operation hat sieben Minuten gedauert oder sowas, fünf, und dann kam man raus und dann habe ich ein Foto mit dem Arzt gemacht, weil die das irgendwie für, na, das ist sehr lustig. Ein völlig verstörter Blick einfach. Der Arzt so Thumbs Up und du einfach, als ob du gerade Tod gesehen hättest. Ich bin aber superh, das war das Sam-Saps-Up-Bild von Floridin.
Wir beide happy, beide Daumen hoch.
Super, eigentlich gut.
Und dann kommt man da raus.
So, und dann war es sehr unangenehm, weil
meine grösste Schwäche,
ich habe viele Schwächen,
aber eine meiner grössten Schwächen,
die ich eigentlich hätte überwinden müssen im Kindesalter, ist,
ich kann die Uhr nicht gut lesen.
Okay. Ich brauche lange. Vor allem, und es ist, alleine geht es sogar noch gut. Aber wenn mich jemand fragt auf der Strasse, wie viel Uhr es ist, tue ich immer so, als wäre meine Uhr kaputt und ich gucke dann auf meinem Handy, wie viel Uhr es ist. Weil ich zu lange brauche, finde ich, um die Uhrzeit mit dem grossen und dem kleinen Zeiger, mit Tick und Tack, ich finde es schwierig. Ob ein oder zwei Sekunden ist dann schon ein Ding. Und das erste, was der Arzt mich fragt nach der Operation ist, gucken Sie mal um uns zur Uhr und sagen, wie viel Uhr es ist. Und ich unter diesem Druck hatte noch nie mehr Druck bei dieser Frage. Ja, klar. Man hat immer schon Druck, weil man schnell deliveren will, aber bei dem Arzt, der gerade in den Augen operiert hat, kannst du nicht versagen. Ich habe die Zahlen klar gesehen, aber ich habe super lange gebraucht, um die
Uhrzeit zu sagen. Und er so,
ja, stimmt schon. Aber war dann so ein bisschen
enttäuscht, mehr intellektuell enttäuscht.
Nicht von seiner Operation, sondern
eher von dir persönlich.
Naja, aber ich konnte danach
schon wieder, und jetzt, heute am
zweiten Tag, ich muss das immer noch irgendwie, gestern musste ich
alle 20 Minuten, musste dann so Augentropfen verschiedene reinmachen,
so Antibiotika, damit es sich entzündet und so ein Scheiß. Und halt so Tränenflüssigkeit, weil es noch ein bisschen zum Austrocknen neigt. Und du musstest viel rein, also dann so einen Film gegeben, so ab, hier bitteschön. Oh nein, nicht ab, kann ich, bei E.T. muss ich auch immer, das reicht leider nicht bei Ihnen, die Dosis muss erhöht werden. So einen halben Tag mit Sonnenbrille rumgelaufen und dann die Tränen liefen so links und rechts runter, Ich sah aus wie ein Witwer. Und ja, heute ist schon wieder super. Also ich muss immer noch wahnsinnig viele Tropfen in meinem Auge ballern, aber mir geht's heute schon wieder gut. Und ich bin gespannt, also wie es jetzt weitergeht. Ich habe jetzt, heute wurde schon gemessen, ich habe wieder eine Sehkraft von 100 Prozent. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich würde es, ich habe, warum ich es nicht schon eher gemacht habe, weil es war jetzt auch am Ende des Tages nicht so wahnsinnig teuer. Ich glaube, auch bei meinen Augen ... Es kann sein, dass es halt, wenn ihr noch Rohrnachverkrümmung habt, oder so was, dass es dann teurer wird. Bei mir war es jetzt echt entspannt. Und ich habe echt gedacht, jederzeit wieder. Und ich glaube, die Risiken sind überschaubar. Ich will jetzt nicht zu viel Werbung machen, muss jeder wissen. Nee, du, glaub mir, ich glaube nicht, dass du Werbung gemacht hast. Das klang wirklich furchtbar. Ich denke mir wirklich, was müsste, was müsste ich erleiden, um sowas durchzumachen? Oder würde ich einfach sagen, okay, dann sehe ich halt nichts mehr. Aber klar, am Ende macht man es so, aber das ist wirklich, vor allem dieses, also ich meine jetzt so in ganz, ganz, ganz niedriger Schwelle fand ich es schon auch immer extrem unangenehm mit diesen ersten Corona-Tests, wo es so ganz tief in die Nase ging. Und da fand ich auch immer das Unangenehmste, dass es man erstes eine und man weiß, ich muss das jetzt nochmal machen. Das ist das Allerschlimmste. Warum hat man denn immer so zwei von jedem Scheiße? Ich meine, das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch natürlich viel schlimmer, aber immer dieses, okay, ich habe es hinter mir, oh ne, fuck, ich muss das ... Wenn du schon weißt, was kommt ... Es kommt genau das Gleiche noch mal. Oh Gott. Das war wirklich in dem Moment kurz sehr, sehr unangenehm. Holy shit. Aber vor allem auch, dass man weiss, dass gerade das Auge aufgeschnitten ist. Das ist eine der unangenehmsten Bewusstseiterfahrungen. Mir wird gerade das Auge aufgeschnitten. Ist so ein Merkw. Und ich hab dann wirklich gedacht ... Also, ich glaub, wenn ihr diese Berührungspille nimmt, habt ihr diese Erfahrung, glaub ich, überhaupt nicht. Hättest du rückwirkend die Berührungspille nehmen sollen? Naja, ich mein, nee, so ist es die etwas bessere Geschichte. Und ich hab's supergut überstanden und war danach super happy wieder. Es gab wirklich diese zwei, drei Sekunden, wo ich dachte, ich muss jetzt gleich kotzen, weil das unangenehm ist, diese Vorstellung, was gerade passiert. Das ist auch viel schlimmer, als was wirklich passiert, ist, dass du gerade weißt, dass dein Auge aufsteht. Und ich habe die ganze Zeit an dich gedacht, weil ich dachte, der kann euch nicht ins Auge schauen, wenn ihr euch in der Nähe des Auges berührt, wenn er wüsste, was gerade mit mir passiert, du würdest einfach zu Hause ... Ich bräuchte die Berührungstablette.
Ich nehme sie für meinen Podcast-Kollegen.
Ja, ja, der wird das schon,
der wird das morgen brauchen, wenn ich das erzähle.
Boah, ey, du, ich habe auch schlechte Augen.
Und jeder sagt mir immer, ey, du brauchst eine Brille oder so,
weil ich sehe fast nichts, gerade so bei Videospielen,
wenn da so viel Gewusel ist, ich sehe nichts.
Boah, ich wäre so stolz auf mich, wenn ich das schaffen würde, aber ich glaube,
das ist noch nicht drin.
Aber mach doch das ohne Vollnarkose.
Diese Zange ist so unangenehm.
Das fand ich aber auch in dem Film so schlimm,
weil ich war ja auch schon mal in einem Filmset
und man ist, am Ende des Tages
wurde dem das ja wirklich eingesetzt
von irgendwen. Der hat sich auch da irgendwie
den Kratzer auf dem Augapfel geholt, der hatte auch
Verletzungen mit, ja, doch, wirklich, doch, recherchiert das mal. Clockwork Orange, Trivia, hat er da auch einfach so einen Kratzer davongetragen, wo ich mir auch denke, vielleicht hat das auch jetzt nicht ein Arzt gemacht oder so am Set. Das denke ich mir nämlich, als ob die einen Arzt holen, einen Aarzt und dem das hinstellen. Oh Gott, im Himmel. Bleibt vonuren Äugleinen weg. Bleibt generell von euren Körperöffnungen weg. Weg von den Körperöffnungen, geht zum Arzt. Fummelt da nicht selber rum, das bringt doch nichts. Schluckt eine Berührungstablette und entspannt euch. Boah, oh Leute, das, okay. Aber jetzt haben wir es beide hinter uns. Jetzt haben wir es überstanden. Du kannst wieder schön sehen, Ist doch gut. Es ist so merkwürdig. Ich glaube, weil wir nicht genau wissen, wir wissen zu wenig über Augen. Deswegen haben wir Angst. Manchmal haben wir Menschen zu viel Angst vor Dingen, die wir gar nicht genau kennen. Inzwischen, so man weiss, die Haut vorne. Man weiss genau, was man da aushält und so. Aber es ist auch der Grund, warum Alkohol erlaubt ist. Weil man es schon so gut kennt. Andere Drogen sind nicht erlaubt, obwohl die vielleicht viel weniger gefährlich sind. Aber es ist so, wir als Menschheit haben uns beschlossen, manche Dinge sehr genau zu erforschen und manche, über die wissen wir nicht so viel. Wahrscheinlich sind Augen sehr gut erforscht, sonst würde es ja auch diese Operation nicht geben, aber wir als gesellschaftliches Bewusstsein wissen zu wenig. Ich würde auch sagen, für den Laien Nichtmediziner ist das Auge das besonderste Körperteil. Es ist wie Magie. Ganz anders als alle anderen. Weil so ein Ohr, okay, das ist halt so ein Hauttunnel. Ja, okay, verstehe ich. Mund, ja gut, auch Hauttunnel, irgendwie Schleimhäute. Hast du eine Zunge, kann man drin rum. Aber Augen sind zwei magische Seelenbälle. Genau, das sind einfach so Bälle, das ist dann wie bei so einem Bubble Tea, so diese Tapioca-Bälle, die dann so zerquetscht werden und da ist dann so Soße drin oder was. Niemand weiß es, ganz furchtbar. Und deswegen reden wir bitte nie wieder über Augen.
Augen sind Fenster zur Seele, für Menschen, glaube ich.
Ja.
So dieses, oh, dieses Magie. Ich glaube, ja, es ist gleichzeitig der schönste Teil, könnte man sagen, des Körpers vielleicht, aber auch einfach widerlich.
Vielleicht gehört das sogar zusammen.
Oh, Leute. Wir haben es hinter uns, ihr habt es hinter euch. Sorry, sorry, sorry für diese Folge. Die Körperöffnungsfolge, warum nicht, muss auch mal sein. Wenn ihr das in Erwägung zieht, irgendwie eure Körperöffnung zu untersuchen oder lasern zu lassen oder wie auch immer, benutzt nicht diese Folge als Grundlage, sondern eure eigene Recherche und vor allem euren Arzt, eure Ärztin. Oh Gott. So viel ist es vorbei.
Wir müssen es hinlegen.
Kurz hinlegen.
Kurz durchschnaufen, kurz mal Fenster auf und durchschnaufen.
Macht das am besten auch, ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
Bis dahin, du darfst noch nicht fahren, ich gehe ans Steuer heute, denn wir heben ab.
Wir heben ab.
It's a Worst Bird production.